okay yeah great so i'd like to talk
about the flare framework and michael
was very good with his introduction so
you basically allow me to skip my first
slide
because you said everything what we do
in my group at the university
is we develop the open source nlp
framework flare so
um and this is really what this talk is
about
um to start at the beginning so we
um the development started in my
previous company so before i joined the
university i was
at zalando research here in berlin uh in
the nlp research department
and the company actually had a lot of
text data that we wanted to analyze
um and for instance we wanted to do a
named entity recognition on this text
data
so zalando because i understand actually
there's a lot of people who are outside
of
berlin in this talk so zalando is
actually a big fashion company
in europe and so basically we had a lot
of text data
in the domain of fashion like this blog
post
right and what we wanted to do is we
wanted to identify
words and groups of words that belong to
certain
semantic categories like colors
or fashion items or like fashion brands
like this kind of stuff so this is
a fairly standard named entity
recognition task
and there were different types of text
mining that we wanted to do
but when we started our work actually we
were kind of unhappy so we looked at all
the research papers or
some of the research papers and we were
kind of unhappy with the general
reproducibility of of the research
results that we were reading about
because they were talking about these
great numbers
and it was somewhat difficult to
reproduce and so some of the problems
that we had
was for instance that some papers only
report the results but don't actually
open source their code
right so you see these great numbers but
it's
pretty hard to actually reproduce them
unless you sit down and
implement it all yourself but the
problem here of course is that a lot of
research papers
don't have all the technical details
right
a special case of this is that some
people say that they will release their
code but they actually never do
but it's the same situation in the end
you don't have the codes
another thing that we encountered a lot
is that code is actually released
that belongs to a paper but it's
actually really hard to get running
right so it's basically really hard to
read
and it has a lot a lot of dependencies
um
so basically we kind of refer to this as
fake reproducibility
because on the one hand the code is
there but on the other hand it's
actually not super usable
and the final case was script producer's
number so we encountered this a few
times
that the research code is released and
it does run
but then it just like this massive
script you get the line that you have to
execute
and it runs forever and at the end comes
out a number let's say 42
that matches the number in the paper but
you really don't know what's going on
right so we were generally unhappy with
the reproducibility and this is
i think it is slowly getting better but
generally this is i think a problem
along in many machine learning
disciplines right so for instance if you
look at named anti-recognition today
or right now if you look at the top five
papers
i think three of them don't actually
open source the code so you can't
reproduce it so it's
it's still it's still a big issue all
right
so we thought okay so what are the dizzy
data for reproducibility so what we like
so this is all very obvious stuff so we
would like a very quick setup
so we would like the framework the
algorithms to be set up very
quickly on your machine but also to
include all the data sets that we need
in order to run the experiments
if the experiments require models such
as embedding models
they should all be included so all of
this should be there right
we also thought it should be modular in
the sense that
the code should be easy to read to
understand what part of the code does
what
and also make it easy to switch out
components so for instance in
nlp you do a lot with embeddings so
let's say you have a research result
that uses glove embeddings
and to make it actually really easy to
switch out a different embedding layer
like a bird embedding layer
in there right we also would like
the code to be applicable to new data
sets and tasks
meaning that the code should not have
any
specific assumptions about the data
right so it should just be usable
to take this research result and apply
it to my task
right and finally it should be easy to
build on top and
i mean if you look at this slide this is
all super obvious right so this is not
no rocket science here and if you do
part of speech tagging and look at the
adjectives on the slides
you're going to find the words easy used
a lot and the word quick
which in this case is cinnamon for easy
so basically what we really wanted
was research that is easy to reproduce
and also research that is easy to apply
and this kind of motivated us to develop
the flair framework
the tagline is a very simple framework
for state-of-the-art nlp
and the two crucial parts are very
simple so it should be easy to use
and state-of-the-art meaning that it
uses recent nlp research
and makes it applicable for for
everybody yeah
flair is built on pytorch which is
a one of the most popular deep learning
frameworks
and it's actually an official part of
the pytorch ecosystem
and it is very very much an open source
project so um
um it's it's an nlp library but there's
no company behind it so we're not
we're not selling it we're not making
any money so basically
the whole development of this project
has basically been driven by
open source community and contributions
from a lot of people so
without the open source community this
project would definitely not exist
and would not look any way like this so
what we originally open source two years
ago
looked very very different from this and
it's actually the involvement of the
open source community that trained new
models and added features and fixed a
million bucks
that that made this framework right
we're currently at version 0.4.5
and we have a new big release coming
this week i wanted to have it done
before this talk but unfortunately
uh it didn't happen so but it's coming
this week
yeah so what
is flare so there's essentially two
views on it
for most users it's an nlp library um
what it allows you to do is to use nlp
models on your text
and there's a lot of models that we just
include and i'm going to show you a
bunch of demos
for some of the models that are included
that you can basically just use as they
are
another thing that a lot of people do is
they use the library to train your own
models because there's a lot of things
like languages or texts
that may be very specific to your use
cases and so the library makes it easy
for you to train your own
nlp models and the uptake actually is
um tremendous so thanks again to this to
the open source community
it's used in hundreds of dependent open
source projects
and i know a lot of companies are using
it in this way a lot of
startups and medium-sized and even large
companies are using it
the other point of view that's more
relevant i think to the
university where i'm at right now is
that it's an nlp experimentation
framework
so essentially there's a big focus on
word embeddings and text embeddings in
the framework
and standard nop pipelines and so
essentially what you can do is you could
develop a new word embedding
or a new text embedding you can plug it
into the framework
and basically run it in default nlp
pipelines
to see what the impact is on downstream
tasks so we include a lot of
like standard data sets and standard
pipelines where you can immediately see
what's going on
however on this talk there's we're not
going to talk about the research
at all instead i'm just going to walk
you through the framework i'm going to
show you how you can use these models
and i'm going to show you maybe time
permitting probably not
how to train your own models okay
okay so we're gonna do a walkthrough
together
uh setting up flare is very easy just
like the previous project all you have
to do is pip install flare
it requires at least python 3.6
and you can do it for instance in an
online environment like colab so it's it
should be very simple to set up
and then once you have this done you can
actually already start
tagging your text one big
task that we support is text
classification
and in text classification what you want
to do is you want to take a piece of
text
and automatically detect whether it
belongs to one or multiple
predefined categories right so a very
classic example of this is sentiment
analysis
so where you want to detect is this text
written in a positive way or in a
negative way
right so somebody writes i really like
this movie because
you want to predict that it's positive
and if somebody writes i really hated
this movie because
you want to predict negative right
and text classification is actually
super versatile you can use it in a
million different use cases
another one is hate speech detection
this is a german example
where you want to find out like is this
speech hate speech
is offensive language yes or no and if
it is offensive language which type of
offensive language is it
so in this example would be
an insult right and in fact it's very
versatile you use it for intent
detection if you use it for many
different use cases
and what i want to do now is i want to
show you a demo of
one of the taggers that we have in flair
in action for sentiment analysis
right so i'm going to try this i'm going
to exit
this so
the first question would be can you see
this can somebody i don't know
michelle maybe yes okay great thanks
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to enter some sentences and we're
going to predict whether the sentiment
is positive or negative
okay so i'm going to start with
this talk is interesting i'm going to be
optimistic
okay so if somebody writes this i click
on the sentiment
and what we can see so i have two
sentiment models one is transformer
based which is the better one
and one is an rnn based model which is
the faster one so they're both packaged
in flare
and as you can see i hope you can see it
this talk is
interesting was classified as positive
by
both models right
if i now go ahead and say this talk is
not interesting
um i do the prediction
and now both models actually very
clearly say this is negative
because it's a very simple example to to
classify right
um to maybe show you a more complex
example
um okay let's say we
we use something that's a little bit
sarcastic right so we say this talk is
about
as interesting
as watching paint dry
so it mentions interesting it doesn't
mention not but it says it's about as
interesting as watching paint dry
so in this case what the models tell us
uh is that
it's a negative right so because this is
an expression you use in english to say
something is boring right
um this word is actually a giveaway this
is about so if i remove
this and i just say this talk is as
interesting as watching paint dry
then i do the sentiment detection as you
can see both models still tell us that
it's negative
but the the confidence has actually
dropped from like 99
to very low confidence 50
right um i'm going to do another one
i'm going to do this talk is as
interesting as watching
let's say a baseball game
if i write this now both my models will
tell me that it's positive
because our models seem to believe that
baseball is interesting
okay um and of course you can do this
with real data as well so i have a new
newspaper article here
and if i put this in this is from a new
newspaper article
you see that this statement which says
something bad about the economy is
is classified as negative right
so to go back into the talk
okay so you have this type of model so
let's say you want to use it yourself
for your use case so basically this is
the full code that you need to do it
as you can see it's only like three or
four lines of code
the most important one is this one so
you do a textclassifier.loadsentiment
the very first time that you call it it
will download the pre-trained model
to your machine and if you
run this code again it doesn't do that
download again so it only does it on the
first
first call and puts it into the object
then you put your text into a sentence
object
you always have to wrap your text into
this object which allows you to
do like a bunch of cool stuff and then
all you really need to do is call
tiger.predict
and then you can print the labels so
it's just a few lines of code
and then you know whether this piece of
text is positive or negative
right
another task that we support a lot in
flare is sequence labeling so i had an
example in the beginning of the talk
[Music]
the most famous one is named entity
recognition where you want to
identify the names of people names
what they are are they names of people
are they names of locations
are they names of organizations or you
want to go into the words and identify
and part of speech tagging
what are the verbs in the sentence what
are the adjectives and again there's a
lot of different use cases why you would
want to do something like this
right and maybe to quickly show you a
demo of this as well
um so this is now the sequence tagging
demo i'm going to show you a few
different models
i'm going to start with a simple
um sentence while you type
i want to read out the question i mean
people are asking where
are the models downloaded from
um so the models are stored on like an
aws
um bucket so basically
yeah they're just downloaded from there
and it's something connected directly to
flare it's like something that
flare basically manages yeah exactly so
this is managed in flare so basically
internally it checks if the model is
already on your hard drive
so there's like a standard folder where
all the models go
and if the model is not there it'll
download it from the
from the web and this is actually not
only for the models this is also for
data sets for instance
so flare actually includes a lot of
different data sets
and also word embeddings so basically
everything that you need there's this
logic it checks if it's there
and if not it'll it'll download it to
your machine
okay interesting
okay cool so to maybe show this sentence
george washington was born in washington
that's by the way not true i'm pretty
sure it's not true
but i use it anyway um to do named
anti-recognition on this sentence will
tell
us that george washington is in fact a
person these two
these two tokens together and washington
is a location
right it's also fairly robust which is
kind of cool
which is why i used this example if i
say washington was born in washington
it'll still know that the first
washington is a as a person
and the second washington is a location
right
to show you the difference between an
entity recognition and part of speech
tagging
i can also just use part of speech
tagging and now what i get
is the syntactic type of each word in
the sentence
for instance i know that born is now a
verb and this can be useful
for certain things where you want to
extract information like
what kind of adjectives are being used
what kind of verbs are being used
right
to go back to presentation
so let's say you want to do any of this
you want to do an entity recognition or
you want to do part of speech tagging
um this is the code snippet and you
might
notice that it looks extremely similar
to the one that i showed you before
that's because there's only one line
that's different and the different line
is this one so you're going to load a
different tagger
obviously right so this time you're
going to type sequence tiger dot load
pos for the power speech tiger
or load ner for the ner tiger and again
the same logic is called so it downloads
the model on the first call to your
machine then again you're going to make
a text object for the text that you want
to classify
and then you're just going to contact it
to predict on the sentence and that'll
predict whatever text the model
is trained to predict right
so that's two tasks that's
text classification and sequence
labeling so
another thing that i'd like to show you
is uh
one model many languages uh
functionality that we have in flair as
well so basically in
in nlp what you typically have is you
have models that are language specific
so you might train a model to do any r
for english you might train a separate
model then to do any r
for german right and this basically as a
means that you always have to do a
language detection first to say to see
which model you should use right but
it's actually possible to train a single
model
using training data from multiple
languages
and especially if we use multilingual
language models which we have in flare
right and what this what then happens is
that the language identification becomes
implicit to the model
so you can actually just give a text in
any languages
and it'll just be able to kind of deal
with it so i want to show you a demo of
this as well
i hope it's not demo overkill
no that's not good
this works this doesn't
okay this works um
[Music]
okay so i hope you can still see
everything
so we go back to the part of speech
tagging example right so we said george
washington was born
in washington um and we know born as a
verb
let's let's add a different language to
this let's say george washington
voter in washington
same sentence in german so i'm gonna i'm
gonna
parse this with the multilingual model
now
and what happens is that even though
it's the same model
seeing text in different languages it's
able to predict
correctly that kebogen is a verb
and born as a verb right so it can
handle this
right another example let's
go into mine
i'm not super sure
somebody correct me please
i think this means george washington was
born in washington in
in french
[Music]
if i do this tagging again at least nay
i'm pretty sure that means born
is tagged as a verb okay so you have
you can actually deal with these models
with text in many different languages
and that
can make depending on your use case if
for instance you have
i don't know for some reason you have a
website where people enter text in all
sorts of languages
this could could be useful for you
okay um there's another question
on youtube by um
zeki and he asks how much data is
necessary to train
uh for different languages in this flair
model i assume
so i mean so the it's always
the more data you have the better so
standard
data sets for sequence labeling tend to
be around
twenty thousand ten to twenty thousand
sentences that are annotated
um i think there's some data sets that
have
less so generally i mean it's always the
more
the more data you have the better at
least so with the universal dependencies
projects there's actually pretty good
data
available for part of speech tagging for
for many different languages
um if that answers the question i i
think that should answer the question
um
maybe another question um that might be
interesting
uh for multiling must languages be from
the same family or does it hold
say between finnish and portuguese
yeah so finnish is actually funny
because it's of course a super crazy
language
so we in this paper that we have here on
the slide we trained it for 12 languages
and i think finnish was actually the the
hardest one of all of them so the other
ones were from
at least the same language groups so um
like romance languages germanic
languages
so it's of course helpful if there's um
if they are in the same group but if you
have sufficient training data for each
language
you can still train a single model that
that does
that works across all these languages so
even finnish doesn't work
it's it's pretty good so
um it's not a must
okay i think we'll continue with the
presentation i'll ask some more
questions
um that are post on youtube and in the
chat later on
yeah sure um
okay so this is maybe i wanted to give a
small list of some pre-trained models
that we have in flare
um so obviously i already showed
sentiment analysis i've showed oh i
didn't actually show the 12 class named
lengthy recognition
so this is 12 classes basically just
more classes so not just person location
and organization but even more
um there is part of speech tagging
for many different languages we have
something called semantic frame
detection
syntactic chunking and we have
multilingual models and i think
there's also models for stuff like hate
speech detection so essentially this is
this is just a lot of models that we
ship with flair
some of them were trained by us many
were also trained by the community
and so um through the open source
community this list is growing and
growing so
um we are supporting more and more
languages with this kind of stuff
so um so far we've seen text
classification
and sequence labeling but we also have a
few other nlp tests that are currently
kind of beta one of them is text
regression
which actually is pretty stable already
so essentially in this case you don't
want to
predict a class label but you want to
predict like a value
like 80 percent or like on a spectrum
right so how how happy is this person
or how unhappy is this person this can
can be useful
depending on your on your use case and
so
we already have the architecture in
flare so you can train your own
regression models
and we also have some data sets that we
already ship with flare
for instance the vasa 2018 shared task
that is data that is annotated with joy
anger fear with certain emotions
on a scale from zero to a hundred okay
so you could train we've done it you can
train models that predict how angry a
person is
just from the text right another thing
that's
it's very very beta but i'm very excited
about this
is similarity learning so here what you
want to do is you
have two data points and these data
points could be two texts but they could
also be
a text in an image which is what we've
been working with and you want to learn
how similar they are so essentially
something like
an image like this dog catching a
frisbee should be very similar
to uh the text uh dog catching a frisbee
in the park
right and for this we include currently
one data set the fidega data set that we
actually developed also
uh which is fashion images so this is
still from the zolando time
in german language descriptions so um
but this is very beta stuff so we we
hope to develop this more because i
think similarity learning is actually
really exciting and there's a lot of
cool things that you can do with it
so here i'm and with all things i'm very
happy to collaborate with people
if anybody's interested in any of this
stuff where we're always happy to
collaborate since this is very much an
open source project
so what is the time
you have another i would say um
five to seven minutes okay then i'm
going to skip over
how to train your own model because it's
something we have tutorials online you
can just check it
um just take my word for it that it's
it's fairly easy to do
yeah um
[Music]
so let me just skip over that
maybe just to show you the very last
slide of that that portion
so this would be a full example of how
to train your model so
i'm not gonna go through the lines one
by one just to show you it's only a few
lines of code
um and it's it's fairly easy to do and
we've
we've seen a lot of people also with
very limited background in python
even in python to to who managed to
train their own models so it's
it's very i think very easy to do
um to conclude then
so i introduced the flare nlp framework
so i showed some
nlp tasks specifically classification
and sequence labeling which really are
the big tasks that we've been focusing
on
i demoed some multilingual models and i
showed you some
code snippets for predicting and
training that hopefully convince you
that the library is in fact
quite easy to use there is a release
coming
this week i promise it will include a
lot of new embeddings new data sets new
pre-trained models
it will include for the first time fine
tunable transformers
which work really well and really have
increased the accuracy for the text
text classification part and there's a
lot of refactorings and simplifications
of the code that we've done
that will be part of the next release
the immediate future will be more so
what we want to do so we want to
actually add more tasks
so next to just these two tasks that
i've demoed
we're interested in branching out to
things like relation extraction
semantic role labeling information
retrieval in the context of similarity
learning
so basically we just want to support way
more tasks
and we feel that it's actually possible
to do it now because now with my
with my new um my new job at the
university
um the manpower situation is looking
very different
so it's i think i've met a lot of very
interested
students uh and i'm very optimistic that
we can actually
get a lot of things done now that
previously we couldn't because we just
didn't have the manpower right we want
to include a lot more data sets and
languages
and apply to new domains we have a
project already running called hunt
flare that will be released hopefully
soon that will just
include a lot of new data sets and
expand flair to new domains
and we're kind of excited about adding
new data types like images or even
complex types
that are kind of combinations between
text and images or semi-structured data
so this is kind of a maybe but i would
would be very interested in doing this
as well
there's a lot of research
[Music]
that of course we're working on at the
university so
this talk was really a focus from the
practitioner point of view
but of course what we do or our day job
is research at the university
so we have a lot of fancy neural
language models that we
want to develop a lot of crazy ideas for
word embeddings that we want to put in
there
we have we want to work more on this
multilinguality aspect and there's a lot
of research in terms of hyperparameter
selection and neural architecture search
so i just
broke this s and i'm going to fix that
because that's important
since we're here at the spelling mistake
there's a question
on youtube regarding the
typos and the correct spelling in the
flare embedding and the flare model what
would happen
how would flair react if the words were
spelt incorrectly
yeah that's a great question so
essentially um
the answer depends on the embeddings
that you use so
our own embeddings that we developed are
character language and
embeddings and they tend to be fairly
robust
to spelling errors but of course it all
breaks down
so not sure which demo i can use best to
show this
let's see what's what ah
let's use this demo
um
let's do this all right see what happens
and for some reason it still is able to
see that
um this is a location
right if you if you guys can see this so
of course at some point
everything just goes goes crazy so if i
do something like this
well okay that still works for some
reason because born i think this is a
very good
let's do something like this okay that
still works
okay so it's it's it's fairly robust so
in um
and the reason for this is that um the
language models that are
powering this at least the flair
language models are at the character
level
um meaning that they they see words as
sequences of characters
and are therefore able to do a lot of
guesswork
right if that makes sense so that's
but i think that's fairly robust yeah i
think that answers the question
perfectly
maybe another question to um uh
like a slide that you showed before
there's this question regarding
um the rnn and transformers that you
loaded
and you used to do the sentiment
analysis i remember correctly
are they both implemented in flare
uh no so basically for
the rnns we just use the default rn ends
that come out of that come with pi torch
and the transformers we completely rely
on the hugging phase
transformers implementation so
[Music]
yes okay thanks
okay then maybe to wrap it up
um yes so i just fixed the join us
because that's a very important part
um yes as i mentioned before so this is
an open source project
there's no company and nobody's making
money
so um this this type of thing really
lives
with people getting involved and people
becoming interested to contribute to the
open source project
so i would like to invite any everybody
to to join us
through the open source project if
you're interested also with
collaborating with my group at the
university
we're very open to any type of of
collaboration
right and so
this is it so we've already had
questions but maybe there's more
questions
thank you
okay thank you very much there there's
another question that
i see uh it's from dol
and he is asking if um
if these models are ever updated
if they're like how are they trained
basically if you train a model is this
model ever
retrained um in a sense
so you have the option of retraining it
so essentially
um i mean the classic pipeline would be
that you train it over your training
data and then you just have
the model um but what is possible is to
take an existing model
and continue training it if for instance
new training data
comes around so for instance i know some
people are using it
in an active learning type scenario
where you add new training data
points over different iterations and in
this case
it's possible to essentially continue
training a model
so the training could never be seen as
complete in a sense so you can always
continue training it if you want to
okay cool um there's another question
on youtube how would you decide whether
to use
tensorflow or pytorch
um so i think i mean this is this is
two years ago so but at the time at
least um
my personal opinion was that pytorch was
way more usable than
tensorflow and in fact it was actually
before tensorflow added this
eager mode functionality so a lot of the
things that we are doing in flare
um would not have been possible with
pytorch
with with tensorflow back then because
we use these dynamic computation graphs
actually a lot
okay cool um uh
i don't see any further questions i
guess
um
oh yeah there's another question about
the french language
is there any model in entity detection
anti-recognition
uh relation extraction in this open
source project
i think we have a french nerd so we
definitely have a french part of speech
tagging model
and i'm pretty sure we have a french ner
model as well
um so french is definitely included in
the multilingual models and i think we
have dedicated models for french as well
so french was not trained by us but it
was trained by a community member
but i'm pretty sure it's there okay
is is it possible to examine a whole
passage or a conversation not only a
sentence to decide
positive or negative sentiment it's
generally possible um
so with transformers currently actually
it's not with a transformer based model
because the transformers have
a a maximum sequence length
that's a hard restriction if you use the
rn based model it is
possible um personally i've
so we've trained the model with passages
of maximum 50 words
because i kind of feel like at some
point if your text is long
there might be multiple sentiments right
if so the
the newspaper article that i just very
briefly showed
has some positive news and some negative
news
so i think it would be kind of hard to
say this i mean you can probably still
say it
but i feel like it's actually maybe more
useful to
if you have a big text to chop it down
and into paragraphs or sentences
and just then do sentiment analysis on
each one of them
um to get your results
okay um there are a couple more
questions um
i think we should start with um
the question about uh flare versus
spacey um what's the difference why
why should i use flare instead of spacey
for example
yeah i'm kind of i'm not super happy
with this kind of question because
i um i actually don't yeah
so i don't have enough experience with
working with spacey myself to answer
this question very well
so the last time i answered it i ended
up saying something that was actually
wrong about spacey
generally i think you should work with
flair
if you like the type of abstraction that
we have so basically this idea of having
access to a lot of
different word embeddings that are
coming out of research right now
and you want to apply this this research
immediately to your
to your projects but at the end of the
day i think it comes down to preference
so
the abstractions that you like the
functionality that you that you prefer
it's it's a it's a bit hard for me to to
give a good good answer to this
okay um there's another question about
um again by draw
this is from the meet up chat
whether the security of these public
models is an issue
i mean basically you could edit the data
or
create some data that will
train in the sense that well some
president candidate
and this will map to negative sentiment
is this an issue
um yeah i mean
so if if you for instance if you
manipulate the training data in such a
way
you could bias the model so that's
that's
possible so in our case we've um
we've used just publicly available data
sets for sentiment analysis so
um in this case it's basically for
instance
the data that we used was trained on
amazon reviews product reviews and movie
reviews
so and there's there's going to be
biases in that data
uh and these biases will be in the model
as well
so yeah that's that can happen okay
but flair doesn't really um
curate the data itself i mean there is
no part of flair that
specifically is responsible for curating
the data and
being responsible in the software like
having some quality measures
for the data set that is used to train
the model
no so basically the only curation we do
is
to kind of try to filter out low quality
volta points
so basically there's always noise
especially in these
in in these data sets so we do filter
out noise
but we haven't really looked into like
this type of political biases or this
kind of stuff
but we're interested so if somebody's
interested in doing that that would be
that would be great
okay um i would say that i'll read
another two
or i think i only see another two
questions on youtube
which is geared towards the
gp t2 and
it's just a general question what do you
think about it what do you think about
gpt2
um
yeah i don't know how to answer that
question it's yeah that's
impressive work so um
i think we include it also and it's also
included via hugging phase transformers
into flare
[Music]
i have not experimented too much with it
so because we actually have a lot of
like different embeddings
so with gpt2 i haven't really worked um
too much so i can't really say too much
about it
okay and i think the last
question if i
um oh yeah that's i think a question
regarding again the sentiment analysis
uh you had an example that
was basically uh one of these borderline
examples where you can't really fix the
sentiment
uh one way or the other where you had
like this 51 percent towards negative
why isn't there a neutral
sentiment the original model we actually
had a neutral sentiment
it's in the end i removed it because
there was too much noise in the training
data so this is really just a problem of
the data set if you have a data set that
has a good neutral charac
category then that's that's great um so
essentially
to go back so so the sentiment data for
the most part is trained over
amazon product reviews where people give
between
one and five stars right and so
the problem is that if people give for
instance three stars
um the language use is actually
extremely different so some people will
say three stars that's
pretty good and some people will give
three stars if something's complete
completely terrible so the model was
actually having differences just because
the signal wasn't that great
the model was having a lot of problems
trying to find out what neutral actually
is
if that makes sense so in the end what
we did is we actually only used
one star and two star reviews as
negative
and only five star reviews as positive
um to just have a better separation of
of language of what what these two
things are
and then we kind of say that if the
because the model always out puts a
probability or like a confidence value
for instance we've seen that the
negative confidence in this one example
was very low
and then in in your use case you could
say
if the confidence is not so high that
it's either negative or positive
then i'm just going to treat this as as
a neutral
[Music]
um okay maybe
one last question which is uh geared
specifically towards you
and uh then i think we'll thank you and
uh because it was a really great talk
um how can i join join you alan via
linkedin question mark yeah sure
hit me up on linkedin that's that's
that's that's totally fine
um join the open source community that's
that's the easiest way
so um uh like i said so we're we're
happy to
to to work together with anyone that
that we can
so okay um
in that case uh i want to thank you and
i think the entire
pi data uh group that is here on
uh zoom and also on youtube uh was i
think very happy with the talk and it
was very interesting
so again thank you for talking
um noah do you want to say something
yeah sure thank you everyone for coming
our next
meetup will probably also be online on
june 17th um
so we had to mystery uh we had the
contest that we announced in the
beginning of the
meetup and we had two contestants from
chile
but they haven't emailed us yet so and
we have been contacted by
the attendee from argentina so now he is
the frontrunner for getting the amazing
pi data stickers
please join us again you can
find us on meetup or on twitter and we
also have
a website which we can quickly post
um on the um
on the youtube chat for people who are
not familiar with pi data building
um matty i hope you're doing it quickly
um yeah and have
everyone a very nice evening
um we have also recorded the talk and
they will be published
sooner than later
okay so i i guess that concludes our
may pi data meetup and we'll see you
next time